I saw like five black ants jump one red
ant before there you go probably have to
is one
took took his
[Music]
Jordans so Ryan did you ever play a game
called Age of Empire no never did you
never you never play this [__] oh this
[__] was so good of course it's a Joe
game that's such a Joe game it's such a
Joe game so Joe you
imagine ja Warcraft but instead of being
Orcs And humans it's just human all
right imagine red alert but it's not
communist thank it's just ancient humans
it's Japanese nationalist so there's
feal feudal Japan you could be Egyptian
I never like the Egyptian even though
they were very powerful cuz they look
like whack which one were you mostly I
like the Japanese obviously I had to
represent my folks and you start in the
feudal time so you love that [__] I love
that you don't even get out I love the
Viking [__] cuz you know I like Vikings
Thor stuff you know mhm but all the
other cultures pretty weak looking yeah
the very weak which one was the weakest
Egyptian yeah Egyptians look weak love
it were there ancient like Native
American type people yeah well I like
those guys too but then they didn't
evolve that much so like they didn't
have pyramids and stuff like that did
you guys know that this game Age of
Empires is being used by Australia to
try to simulate ant War Warfare War so
did you guys know that ants actually
have wars with each other crazy Wars and
we don't really we can't really un we
don't necessarily understand all of the
inner workings of how ants have combat
like but they actually do kind of have
similar uh tactics to what or at least
we have maybe copied some of those uh
over the years or they kind of match up
because that's how you do Warfare I saw
like five black ants jump one red ant
before there you go probably have to is
it one of those took his SHO
[Laughter]
took his
Jordans cuz the red one was [__] huge
and all the other on were small they're
[__] jumping his ass [__] they
killed him I didn't watch the whole
video so using this game right AG of
Empires they they built armies and
Battlegrounds of different sizes and
shapes and then watched the ants fight
and mapped out the results on like a
heat map wow wow cool yeah they was like
they should have used Starcraft instead
cuz ants can fly too yeah and build uh
you know cannons and stuff yeah and they
find space and stuff no but the aliens
look like the ants they could have used
Sim ant that's already a game yeah dude
ant farms are
very interesting yeah you ever watched
those videos yeah dude I think they're
[__] pretty tight cuz it's the
nerdiest [__] ever right imagine you
have an ant farm you're like dude you
get beat up for having one of those did
your school have one there's nerdier
things but I looked at it and I'm like I
could watch this all day ant farms are
are really fun to watch really they're
really good they're really fun when they
get filled with molten that's my [__]
molten aluminum dude that shit's pretty
cool I love that [__] they take that
[__] out oh my god when I when it's
summertime and I'm killing ants all
[__] week long I watch that [__] at
night and I pound my dick to
it the best bro I hate ants we should
get ant farm for the ants or mosquitoes
oh mosquito dude mosquitoes got to go go
hate mosquito there's no isn't there
like no ecosystem benefit to having
mosquito no to kill people that's why
Bill Gates is making more of them we got
one of those electric zappers in in the
gym cuz we get mosquitoes sometimes and
nothing gets our rocks off when you hear
did you know that why we have mosquitoes
finally in Vegas cuz Bill Gates Bill
Gates been injecting them with Co to
give it give us Co y but it's actually
because we've been
monsooning much more precipitation than
we usually have right they have another
breed of mosquitoes that they found in
2016 yeah where they come from where did
they come from but it's not Co
mosquitoes but they've been multiplying
in the Vegas area and there's been more
water puddles cuz it hasn't been as dry
yeah hopefully it dries up soon yeah so
then they die y but there's a lot more
there's dude when it was sunset the
other day we were just like what the
[__] is happening dude this never
happens we need to figure out mosquitoes
one of them got in our house that's been
[__] Nicky up nonstop same one huh
get electric rocket dude he's alive
still I'm getting a bite every night
damn they all show up during the um
Sunset I feel like during the sunset
they all like just start [__] feeding
sunrise and sunset as you get your
ankles wrecked yeah ankles are destroyed
Annihilation I get and they chill cuz
it's too hot they're like it's hot
[__] hate mosquitoes [__] mosquitoes
if we could figure out a way to kill
them all we millionair ants could be I
I'm down with I like them but then the
activists are going to come out and like
block the freeway over they could be
[__] swimming in a nest in the
mosquitoes dude if you defend mosquitoes
you should be run over by a car you
should be [__] yeah you should be their
food um so you guys know that ants are
an invasive species especially in
Australia they they sort of really yeah
and they're at war with each other uh
and so they're trying to understand more
about how they fight one another so that
they can help cuz they spend hundreds of
millions of dollars every uh year to
eradicate them hundreds of millions yeah
so trying to understand more of how they
move and how they migrate using a game
like Age of Empires is maybe going to
help them like better that's a sick ass
way for someone in the office to just
try to play games that's what I'm saying
it's sick guys now I got to use NBA Jam
to see how these guys are
fighting so we're we're going to have to
and then they they start to stretch it a
little bit to see what they can get away
with like we're going to have to play
Tekken um for a couple of weeks for hand
toand combat is actually way more
sophisticated than we thought and and
then they they have their their annual
and they're like I think I deserve a
raise I'm playing a lot of [__]
Mortal Kombat 2 put a lot of hours in
like Tekken was really really helpful
but we need to deepen the research so
Killer Instinct is on the maybe it's old
caliber I don't know Killer Instinct
gold we've been playing Killer Instinct
regular it's like kind of like we we
want better graphics we can understand
what the ants are going to
do dude if that's what this whole
thing's about that's genius that's what
I'm saying dude that's genius hope I
don't buy any of this [__] I don't buy
Age of Empire don't you have to like
build like like a like a like a school
for your town or something like that and
it's this one of those G I think you
have to build an Empire you ever yeah
you got you got to educate the the
people dude you ever play Civilization
is the same thing the OG same [__] but
that's the OG one where like you're
playing and then you realize like holy
[__] it's 5: in the morning yeah oh see
so you do know Age of Empires I didn't
play Age of Empires but I played
civilization family I haven't played it
is it the same same [__] you go into war
looks like it yeah when was the last
time you played Age of Empire I Haven to
be honest I haven't played games for at
least five years good for you I know is
Age of Empire like a very modern it's
old bro I played Sims 3 probably like a
week ago did you I'm sad I still play it
I can't play games you do disasters on
your own [__] no no not in Sims do
disasters oh dude you just click the
button at the top you say Alien Invasion
Alien Invasion for S you can like what
what happens when you have Alien
Invasion oh it [__] up your city it's a
way to challenge yourself to see if you
can recover from a disaster oh is that
what it's for technically what it's for
I just said I just want to see it burn
see if you can maintain manage resources
of your City to recover after like a
mass fire or something wait Sim City Sim
City yeah is there a CO option but I do
know disaster there's tornado in the
update yeah I do no disasters for Sim
City cuz I just want to grow the city
and make money no boring I I just want
to be a city developer you know it's
interesting though because you have to
handle taxes for like the people oh [__]
yeah it's pretty sounds like tons of fun
yeah that's why I turned it all the way
on very easy mode destroy all my [__]
but the idea of someone using a game to
get better at their job like this such
[__] can you imagine going into City
Hall and everyone's playing Sim City and
City Hall yeah maybe the city would
actually operate better you would
probably just have to watch the ants
right that's how you get better at that
job so dude I mean the funny thing is
that the the the reason why it's so
ridiculous because there's games like
cityscape or like there's a lot of city-
based games that are good games because
they have real City people Consulting to
make the game so to do it the other way
around is so Dume well D but think about
it it's like it took a guy doing his job
to make the game think about this you're
in Australia it's probably hot as
[__] [__] and you're like let's make
some [__] up we can stay inside and play
games all day yeah they don't want to go
outside and test [__] ass apples
you're the scientist you're like I'm the
expert we need to be playing like
[__] Modern Warfare 3 dude they just
want to run they just want to run up F
all happened the reason this whole thing
happened a guy got caught at work I'm
daring it for work and they're like it's
not what it looks like he got caught and
he's like that's his story and then the
supervisor that's remarkable he's like
he's like we've been [__] up with
these ants I just thought we'd approach
it in a new way exactly yeah he like and
it just got blown out of proportion now
it's on Daily
Mail and they're like the Liberals are
out of control I go watch an an farm for
a while did you guys not like my take
when I said they were interesting um we
just didn't think it was a little exting
did you do you actually watch do you
actually watch him though cuz I watch it
and I'm like this is fascinating and I
want to [__] up the guy just because I
have to out of principle yeah but then
you know what other [__] was dope too
the the [__] planetarium [__] the
planetariums dude they just make up a
whole jungle and it's like a fish tank
and then the like the guys that are into
fish tanks that oh dude I've seen the
guys make mini ones like in mini mini
little tiny bottles fish tank oh yeah
the eems yeah that [__] is cool have you
seen the [__] using gasoline to
kill [__] wasps what G yes they get
like a cup full of gas and then they
just go up like this and then the vapors
just make the Ws just start dropping
yeah the second the cup goes there all
of them fall and they die right away W
and I saw one this morning that had like
millions of [__] views on Tik Tok is
like the second he did that he like
drained out the gas put them all out but
because all the Wasps were dead and full
of gasoline he liit that [__] and he had
bonfire of was wow I wonder which street
fighter that guy had to play to figure
that
out which Super Mario yeah that was a
yoga flame Mario Sunshine Mario Sunshine
Luigi's
[Music]
Mansion